Douwe Egberts setup a face recognition coffee
maker that dispenses a cup of coffee when
it detects a person yawning.
And Celest-jewel-ale is a new beer from Dog
Fish Head Brewery that is steeped with lunar
meteorites - received from a company that
makes NASA spacesuits and once it's gone - it's
gone forever!
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
Researchers now say that the hemispheres of
Albert Einstein's brain were unusually well-connected
and that could have contributed to his brilliance.
After his death in 1955 Einstein's son allowed
the nobel-prize-winning physicist's brain
to be studied and while last year it was noted
that he had a dramatically expanded prefrontal
cortex - a new technique to study the corpus
callosum - developed by Weiwei Men of East
China Normal University's Department of Physics
found Einstein had more extensive connections
between certain parts of his cerebral hemispheres
compared samples of 15 elderly men and 52
men Einstein's age in 1905.
Arc Nova is an inflatable concert hall.
Created by architect Arata Isozaki and sculptor
Anish Kapoor - the structure takes about two
hours to inflate and holds around 500 people.
The arc was made to tour the areas of Tohoku
that were devastated by the earthquake and
tsunami in 2011 and they're looking to bring
back hope and encouragement to the cities
via music, design, and culture.
Blizzident is a 3D-printed toothbrush that
thoroughly cleans your teeth as you grind
and bite down on it -- in just 6 seconds.
Hana Yakiniku wants your smartphone to smell
like food.
By attaching the device you can pick the food
you want and then smell it while eating something
plain like white rice or lettuce.
It's supposed to work well for people on budgets
or on a diet, and comes in many different
scents like coffee, coconut, curry, and cinnamon
roll.
Hawkes Ocean Technologies has created The
Deepflight Super Falcon a kind of underwater
plane.
It has the ability to do barrel rolls and
jump out of the water because of its wings
making it more like an underwater plane that
a typical submarine.
Their commitment to using electric energy
makes it safe to operate around humans and
marine life, and they're taking orders for
them right now.
Mollusks have teeth made of magnetite which
is the hardest material made by a living organism,
ever.
So Yeah.
Yaskawa electric is making a device to help
people that have suffered from a stroke to
be able to walk with more ease.
It's similar to the boot that stroke victims
currently use but it's now motorized to help
lift and move the user's leg forward giving
them a longer and more confident stride.
A sensor inside the boot detects when the
user is walking and starts to automatically
assist, allowing them to take bigger steps
and they're shooting for commercial availability
by 2015.
The PicoBrew Zymatic is the world's first
all grain in home beer brewing system.
It's essentially an espresso maker for beer.
All you have to do is load up your hops and
barley, choose the kind of beer you want,
press go and let it do its thing.
Within a couple of hours the beer is made
and all of the data is sent to your computer
so you can save your favorite recipes.
Meanwhile, Monsieur is a robotic bartender
that learns its user's tastes and customizes
the drinks depending on each person.
Using a touch screen you can browse through
the cocktails and once you pick a drink you
choose its strength whether you want normal,
lightweight, or boss.
It even emails a grocery list to your local
liquor store to schedule a delivery when you're
running low on ingredients.
The Pinocchio lizard is BACK!
Thought to be extinct for the last 50 years....it
was recently observed by Tropical Herping
in Ecuador.
Engineering students at Rice made this robotic
arm for a teenager named Dee who suffers from
a brittle bone disease.
The project lasted two years and resulted
in this cool robotic arm that gives Dee the
ability to safely pick things up and become
more independent just in time for him to start
college.
Split are the worlds first stand alone audio
player with no cables and doesn't require
bluetooth.
It's completely hands free and you can adjust
the volume and change tracks by using bite
clicks - but you can lock them so you can
bite without altering the music.
Finally here is Kaleidolapse from mylapse,
a beautiful video of different time lapse
shots with a kaleidoscopic effect.
I'm going to leave you with self assembling
robot cubes and as always - thanks for watching.